interesting what you said earlier about
there are certain things that they're
able to do that we're not you like
factchecking and stuff they're also
because of how they're incentivized and
subsidized and the
expectations like non-sexy stories you
know digging
into weather and accounts and stuff tell
me which YouTube channel is going to
predict tomorrow's weather no one right
not sexy enough too much of a cost to be
able to do and no one's saying the
Met Office they're captured by
the woke although there was that thing
this year right where they made most of
Europe look like it had turned to Ash
because anything over 35 degrees Cel
meant that it was like the blackened end
of a cigarette so maybe there is a
little bit incredible I mean
going on yeah well there is a lot of
going on what's interesting is
there's no I find the climate issue
absolutely fascinating it's genuinely
fascinating to me because the the
hisorical ignorance on that issue that
is being deliberately spread is is like
mind-blowing to me do you know the
Romans when they occupied Britain they
grew grapes on hadran's wall hadran's
wall for people listening is what used
to protect England from Scot from what
is now Scot what is now England from
what is now Scotland right one of the
northernmost points on the British Isles
uh now if you don't know Scotland
cold it's average weather in I
used to live in Edinburgh for seven
years average weather in Scotland in in
August is like 18° in rain at best right
so uh the the what we are being told
about that issue is absolutely
mind-blowingly incredibly unhelpful and
inaccurate wasn't the I think it's still
around somewhere in London or somewhere
in the South Coast 40 miles in land from
the coast as ports py castle Yeah pavy
Castle you go there and they're like
like Yeah The Sea used to be here I
don't see the SE 2000 years ago yeah
so this whole conversation is very very
odd to me and uh after my Oxford speech
went viral I I had a lot of invitations
to go and speak to different people and
I I was talking to this guy who works
for the Indian government at a high
level and he told me when when India
became independent in 1947 average life
expectancy was 37 years old in India and
today it's I think
82 and that's because they burn fossil
fuels now are we saying to a billion
plus Indian people they're not allowed
to do that anymore do you know what I
mean like the way we talk about this
issue just it it's it's Ault it doesn't
make any sense it doesn't make any
logical sense the things that are being
suggested that we do don't make any
sense the way we're approaching it
doesn't make any sense it's it's
incredible to me the way this
conversation's being had um and I and
I'd love to understand you know Eric who
you just had on he always says this like
we lying about the climate for the wrong
reasons do you know what I mean like
it's like his point is climate change is
happening and it's a serious issue but
we're lying about the way to deal with
it and lots of other things around it um
that's one of the most weird things to
me about what's happening like bjon
lumor during that oh my God Heat Wave
we're all going to die kept posting
stuff about you know like actually the
number of forest fires is the lowest
it's ever been then the number of
hurricanes in America etc etc etc and I
would love to know what's going on with
that I would love to know because
you got
theories
um well one thing that's interested me a
lot is obviously people are familiar
with the concept of group think but
there's another thing which is um the
the abene Paradox I don't know if you're
familiar with it uh it's basically the
idea that people will often do things
because they think other people want
them done um and you combine that with
mass panic indoctrinating kids into
being terrified Etc and I also think
human beings love a doomsday narrative
and a a portion of the sort of side that
I've been arguing on which is this
anti-woke side is like The Barbarians at
the gates now I genuinely think that's
true I think we are undermining the
founding pillars of our civilization but
there is an appeal to that worldview and
if you look back neither of us are old
enough but in the 1970s the planet was
Cooling and every everybody was
terrified of global cooling terrified
terrified of the population bomb
absolutely now we're terrified of the
depopulation it it's what we love we
love to think and I think there's a kind
of like we live in special times oh like
a mass toyis yeah like look look you
know the last 2,000 years you know
has happened and you know you had Jesus
you had World War II and whatever but
now is the real time when is
happening you know and who knows maybe
it is happening U not on this issue I
don't think but yeah the idea that we
are living through a climate catastrophe
seems highly suspect to me highly
suspect but also somehow very sexy very
sexy now that's not to say the climate
isn't changing the climate is changing
but the question I think we also ought
to be asking is is the climate changing
a bad thing well climate related deaths
have decreased by 50 times over the last
100 years that's Alex Epstein has he
been on yeah we haven't had him on but
yes oh dude you I mean you guys would
love him I'm sure
uh he's an interesting dude yeah uh
climate related deaths have decreased by
50 times more people are killed by cold
weather than hot weather yes way way way
way more and we know that because this
is the thing about the idea of pursuing
that zero is it makes energy more
expensive that's the method by which you
achieve this to some
extent uh and tens of you know
pensioners freeze to death every winter
in this country now that doesn't seem
like a good thing to me I don't think
making energy more expensive for poor
elderly people and them freezing to
death on their own in their homes in the
winter I don't think that's what I don't
think if we were setting out to improve
the world that would be one of the ways
that we'd do that but because we're
trade-off denialist because we refuse to
understand that actions have
consequences good and bad um we ignore
that uh and this
hysteria it's cult-like and it it it's I
find it very strange I find it very
strange whatever you think about the
climate issue in and of itself our
response to it is strange this episode
is brought to you by short form short
form is my absolute favorite way to
discover new non-fiction books and gain
deeper insights into books that I've
already read you guys know about how
important my reading list is to me and
short form is an easier faster and
cheaper way to dive into ideas that I've
always been curious about they're
essentially book summaries on steroids
they provide super detailed Guides of
the book's key ideas and they've got
smart insights and interactive exercises
I really love using short form to
revisit some of my all-time favorite
books like the 48 Laws of Power by
Robert Green they've got onepage
summaries and breakdowns of each chapter
that will help you to better absorb and
solidify all of the learnings without
having to go back through a book that
you've already read the best part is
that they always keep their Library
fresh short form drops new book guides
and articles every week and subscribers
get to vote on what books to cover you
can try short form completely free for 5
days with no obligation by following the
link in the description or by going to
short.com Modern wisdom and you'll get
an additional 20% off if you sign up for
the annual subscription that's short
form.com
slod wisdom thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that clip then
press here for the fulllength 2our plus
podcast with
Constantin